this just in
miramax has changed the title of mighty
aphrodite
to il sorvino
to present the cinematography oscar we
have the star of the ace ventura movies
a man who has absolutely no trouble
filling a camera lens
ladies and gentlemen mr jim carrey
everybody's talking at me
i don't hear a word they're saying
i gotta admit to you you know i i don't
get a chance to see a lot of movies
lately i'm kind of busy and
and uh until i saw that whole piece on
commuter animation i
i thought these were the midnight cowboy
dolls and
and i bought them and i brought them
home and i've been playing with them
i got a whole thing you know my name is
joe book
and i'm going to new york city to be a
street hustler
and i was i was wondering about this one
i didn't think it was very accurate you
know
but i still had fun with it what am i
doing on a space suit
i don't want to go to space i want to go
to miami
hey i'm walking here i'm working here
couple of announcements uh the producers
told me to tell anybody who comes up to
the podium tonight to just go ahead and
stretch
show is short uh and i know you know you
people don't like
when guys get up here and espouse their
political beliefs i just
want to say one thing viva el salvador
thank you
sorry to take your time with that
and now to the visited business at hand
in the collaborative art of filmmaking
the cinematographer is often the most
important
unsung hero let me tell you what these
artists do
it's a cinematographer who becomes the
painter of a film
mixing light lenses camera movement film
processing and digital technology
all of which help set the context for
film's mood telling the story
cinematically now let me tell you what
basically that all means
they take people who look like this
and through the use of proper filters
and soft lenses
try to turn them in to this
this year five cinematographers
nominated by their peers represent the
best
stephen goldblatt for batman forever
john toll for braveheart emmanuel
lubesky for a little princess
michael coulter for sense and
sensibility
lou you for shanghai triad
who will take home the lord of all
knickknacks
the king of tchotchke
the oscar goes to john toll for
braveheart
thank you very much thank you mel gibson
for giving me an opportunity to be a
part of braveheart
and making it a great experience and
i'd like to share this award with a
wonderful cast the great crew
production designer tom sanders
assistant director david tomlin
three second unit directors of
photography john clothier eddie collins
and ray stella
and on behalf of all of us thank you
very much
you